guau pues estoy muy emocionado porque
vamos a resolver el problema número 20
el último problema que me queda en esta
sección ahora no solamente por eso estoy
muy emocionado sino porque también veo
este problema y creo que es un problema
bastante increíble creo que nos va a
divertir mucho y se ve bastante
interesante así que manos a la obra
ahora ten cuidado porque creo que este
problema no está tan fácil como parece
vamos a trabajar con este problema y lo
que nos dice es lo siguiente lo primero
que me dicen es que aquí tengo un cuarto
de circunferencia que por cierto tiene
radio rte o radio r ese y mide seis
unidades de radio por lo tanto la
distancia que hay de aquí
atacan hasta que este dignidades ok y de
igual manera para acá lo que hay de aquí
hasta acá hasta acá son seis unidades
todo esto son seis unidades ahora lo que
nos preguntan es cuánto vale el
perímetro de la parte sombreada el
perímetro de esta parte sombreada y ojo
lo voy a poner con otro color para que
lo visualice es mejor lo que quiero es
el perímetro de esta parte más esta
parte más esta parte más a toda esta
parte de atrás antes de ponerla con este
color toda esta parte todo esto es lo
que yo quiero saber cuánto vale su
perímetro y ahora para obtener el
perímetro de esto me dan un último dato
un último dato que es bastante
importante
me dicen que este rectángulo que tengo
aquí adentro este rectángulo de aquí
cumple que el largo del rectángulo más
el centro del rectángulo suman ocho
unidades ok si este es el ancho de
extract ángulo le voy a poner a de ancho
y este es el largo de este rectángulo le
voy a poner el largo entonces el largo
más el ancho esto me da una suma de ocho
unidades la suma de estos dos me dan
ocho unidades ok no se nos olvide este
dato porque lo vamos a ocupar yo lo que
quiero obtener es el perímetro de todo
esto verde que tengo aquí pero este
perímetro lo podemos ir separando poco a
poco en varios pedazos así que primero
concentrémonos en el primer pedazo que
se me ocurre a mí sea este de aquí voy a
tomarme solamente la parte de acá afuera
todo esto todo este pedazo es lo primero
que quiero calcular y para esto me
quiero fijar en
marcó un arco de la circunferencia si te
das cuenta este arco equivale a un
cuarto del perímetro total la
circunferencia así que si hablamos de la
circunferencia entera la circunferencia
tiene como perímetro el perímetro de la
circunferencia es igual a pi por
diámetro o dos veces por radio esta
fórmula ya sabemos desde mucho tiempo
dos veces pine por el radio ok pero en
este caso tenemos un radio de seis
unidades recuerda que el radio rte o el
radio r ese mide seis unidades por lo
tanto el perímetro de la circunferencia
es igual a 6 por 2 lo cual es 12 12 pi
muy bien ahora ojo si yo me quiero fijar
solamente en esta parte de aquí en este
arco de aquí entonces el perímetro de
este arco de aquí de este arco quién va
a ser bueno si nosotros sabemos que esto
es un cuarto de circunferencia y ese
dato nos lo dan entonces pues está muy
fácil lo que hay que hacer es tomarnos
el perímetro total de toda la
circunferencia integral
la conferencia entera y a ese perímetro
total lo voy a dividir entre 4 por lo
tanto el perímetro de este arco es 12
pib entre 4 porque solamente me estoy
tomando un cuarto de la circunferencia
lo cual por cierto estrés para entonces
ya está la medida o la longitud de este
arco de aquí es 3 pib y como lo vamos a
ocupar más adelante déjenme atraparlo
porque esto nos va a servir bastante en
nuestro siguiente parte del problema
ahora yo creo que la clave la clave de
este problema viene justo en este
momento fíjate bien qué pasa si yo
atrapo esta parte de aquí a esta parte
de aquí vamos a fijarnos ahora en la
longitud de esta parte de aquí bueno tú
te puedes quebrar la cabeza pensando en
la longitud de esa parte de aquí o la
otra y lo otro que se me ocurre es que
tal vez conservar la calma y te fijes
que esta distancia de aquí es
exactamente la misma que otra que si
conocemos fíjate bien esta distancia
estará tan gul o es exactamente la misma
que a distancia de este rectángulo y
aquí está la clave para mí de este
problema estas dos distancias estas dos
diagonales son iguales esta diagonal y
esta diagonal son iguales porque tenemos
un rectángulo y además este rectángulo
kutxa la propiedad de que toca o están
gente a la circunferencia en este punto
en el punto b por lo tanto qué distancia
hay de rb bueno pues lo piense tantito
la distancia de ravel es la misma que de
rate que es la misma que drs porque r es
el centro de la circunferencia y como r
es el centro de la circunferencia la
distancia que hay en cualquiera de esos
radios son seis unidades entonces la
distancia que hay de aquí hasta acá son
seis unidades dicho de otra manera la
distancia que hay de esta diagonal son
seis unidades y por lo tanto la
distancia que hay de esta diagonal de
color anaranjado también son seis
unidades eso es muy importante esta
distancia son seis unidades y creo que
esta es la parte más importante de todo
el pueblo date cuenta que estas dos
diagonales miren lo mismo y que esta
diagonal mide seis unidades porque es un
radio de esta circunferencia y por lo
tanto esta también va a medir seis
unidades ok ahora pensemos en la parte
de verdad vamos a pensar en estos que me
quedan aquí
además los voy a tomar juntos me va a
tomar esta parte de aquí me voy a tomar
esta parte de aquí déjenme cambiar un
color verde un poco más llamativo esta
parte de aquí y esta parte de aquí jaja
creo que no mejoró mucho bueno lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que quién o
cómo puedo encontrar esta parte de aquí
bueno esta parte de aquí a quienes no
sabemos cuánto valen pero qué te parece
si nosotros a esta parte de aquí la
llamamos a seis unidades porque de aquí
hasta acá hay seis unidades todo esto
son seis unidades ya esto le voy a
quitar a el ancho si a seis unidades le
quitó el ancho me queda esta parte de
aquí que es justo lo que yo quiero
obtener por lo tanto esta parte de aquí
es 6 menos el ancho y de igual manera
usando una lógica muy parecida nosotros
podemos decir que esta parte de aquí
cuanto vale bueno pues si de aquí acá
hay seis unidades y a esto le quitó el
largo de libertad ángulo entonces esta
parte del verde es lo mismo que seis
menos el agua porque se alargó le sumo
esta parte de aquí obtengo un radio
completo ok entonces creo que ya sabemos
bastante información vamos a ver que
podemos obtener vamos recopilando la
información que tengo el perímetro el
perímetro de lo que yo quiero el
perímetro de toda esta parte sombreada
que tengo aquí quien va a ser bueno pues
en primer lugar son 3 pib 3 pin ya esto
le tengo que sumar a 6 recuerda que esta
distancia 6 entonces debe sumar 6 ya
esto le tengo que sumar a pues este
pedacito de aquí pero este pedacito de
aquí vale 6 menos a es más déjenme
ponerlo con un mismo color
el perímetro es igual a quien bueno es a
33 piques esta parte de aquí ok ya esto
le tengo que sumar a 6 a esto lo tengo
que sumar 6 que es esta parte de aquí
esta diagonal ya esto le tengo que sumar
pues esta parte de aquí esta parte de
aquí que 6 - l
6 - l a esta conclusión llegamos y a
esto le tengo que sumar esta parte de
aquí pero esta parte de aquí es lo mismo
que 6 menos a y de aquí ya podemos
obtener a una suma de términos comunes
fíjate bien tengo este 6 este 6 y este 6
se pueden sumar y me quedaría que el
perímetro es igual a 3 y 6 más 66 es 18
más 18 ya esto le voy a quitar el m ya
esto le voy a quitar am pero aquí está
la segunda clave de este problema menos
el menos a esto es exactamente lo mismo
que ver 3 pib
18 - - y fue a factorizar lo menos menos
que multiplica a l por una parte y por
otra parte multiplica a y ya está 3 pi
más 18 - l más y esto en paréntesis
porque si distribuyó este menos me
quedaría menos l menos a que es justo lo
que tengo aquí arriba ok y ahora también
viene el segundo paso muy importante que
te digo porque recuerdan que este es un
problema que tiene solución y como este
problema está en el examen ese tema debe
de tener solución lo importante es
encontrar la solución y para eso yo
siempre te recomiendo que cuando tengas
un problema de matemáticas recuerdes
todos los datos que te dan casi siempre
en todos los problemas de matemáticas
todos los datos los vas a utilizar para
resolver el problema por ejemplo aquí ya
utilizamos que el radio vale 6 que este
es un radio este es un radio ya
utilizamos a cómo se saca el perímetro
de la circunferencia pero es lo que no
hemos utilizado es esta
y que el masaje es igual a 8 y por
cierto es uno de los datos más
importantes que me dan del problema por
lo tanto vamos a usarlo para terminar
este problema ojo recuerda cuáles son
los datos que te dan para utilizarlos
todos en la solución de tu problema
entonces el perímetro que es lo que yo
quiero es igual a 3 pi
+ 18 menos y cuánto vale el más amo a
bueno pues se le masa aquí nos dicen que
vale 8 por lo tanto vamos a sustituir
todo este valor todo esto lo voy a
sustituir aquí y entonces me va a quedar
3 más 18 menos 8 lo cual por cierto ya
lo tenemos 3 pimas 18 menos 8 es lo
mismo que tres más días entonces el
perímetro de esta parte sombreada estrés
y más
y por cierto este es el inciso b por lo
tanto si está en nuestras respuestas y
ya están aquí tenemos la solución de
este problema el perímetro de esta parte
que voy a poner justo ahorita de esta
parte de aquí más esta parte de aquí más
esta parte de aquí más toda esta parte
de aquí más toda esta parte de aquí más
todo esto más todo esto más todo esto
más todo esto más todo esto el perímetro
de todo esto es 3 mil más 10 y bueno lo
que sí quiero decirte es que lo más
importante de este problema fueron dos
cosas la primera visualizar que está
diagonal es exactamente lo mismo que
esta diagonal y esta parte es muy
difícil yo creo que ahí es justo cuando
uno cambia de ser una persona inmadura
en matemáticas a una persona madura en
matemáticas cuando pueden visualizar
este tipo de cosas buscar la solución
del problema implica también el buscar
cómo encontrar los datos que me faltan y
en este caso fue darnos cuenta que está
diagonal y ésta tienen la misma longitud
y el segundo para la segunda parte
importante de este problema fue utilizar
todos los datos recuerda que aquí nos
dan el dato de que el masa es igual a 8
y esto lo tenemos que utilizar tarde o
temprano por lo tanto nos dimos cuenta
que lo podríamos utilizar justo al final
aquí cuando factor es el menos el
envasar y entonces ahora se puede
sustituir esto por 8 y encontrar la
solución de este problema date cuenta de
lo importante que es este problema bueno
pues nos vemos en la siguiente
sección en la sección número 9 del
examen número 6 hasta la próxima